saludos de esta cantidad quiero que
analicemos el valor que representan
estos números 4 de aquí de acá pensemos
en lo que representa cada uno de estos
dígitos dependiendo de la posición en
donde se ubican tenemos aquí las
unidades
le siguen las decenas después van las
centenas después los millares
y finalmente las decenas de millas
decenas de millas bueno comparemos los
valores por posición aquí este 44 por 10
millares 4 por 10.000 que es igual a 40
mil por otra parte tenemos este 4 que
está en la posición de las escenas y es
4 por 10 cuyo valor es de 40 esté 40.000
tiene cuatro ceros y el 40 sólo tiene un
cero para que fueran iguales tendríamos
que multiplicar cuarenta por mil el
cuatro de aquí es mil veces más pequeño
que este cuatro de la izquierda otra
forma de pensar en esto es que cada vez
que nos movemos un lugar hacia la
izquierda vamos aumentando el valor de
la posición por un factor de 10 es decir
de aquí a acá de las unidades a las
decenas esto se multiplica por 10
si nos movemos de aquí acá aumenta por
10 un factor de 10 y vamos a tener
centenas 11 seguido de 20 lo mismo que
hacemos acá se aumenta por 10 y ahora en
lugar de tener 100 tenemos 1000 o
millares y finalmente los multiplicamos
por 10 y ahora son decenas de miles y
así de aquí de este 4 que están las
decenas al 4 que está en las decenas de
millas de aquí acá son 123 una
diferencia de mil
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo